hey guys it's guy for today if I work
tonight or if you prefer simply the
fifth of November my name is just
McDonald and you're watching gamespot
news the sub rockstar wanted to give you
a really good reason to pick up GTA 5 on
current-gen consoles and they've
released a graphics comparison trailer
to convince you the video compares the
ps3 version to the upcoming ps4 version
and they do look vastly different part
of this is a result of the double draw
distances letting you see a whole lot
further and the replacement of every
single texture in the game the video
depicts hugely detailed wildlife and
flora character models and crazy
gorgeous water not to mention city
lights reflecting offset water as well
as cars and helicopters and what have
you call of duty advanced warfare dev
sledgehammer games reckon it's time to
go back to the world war two cod games
the devs co-founder Michael condry said
I think a next-generation game with the
latest production values and robustness
in a world war 2 setting like band of
brothers would be amazing although he
did note that diminishing the new
movement abilities introduced alongside
advanced warfare exosuit would be
difficult while Kandra made a point that
the call of duty franchise is known for
ripping at stories from the headlines he
doesn't think all headlines are right
for CoD games explaining i think the
tragedies going on around the world in
the areas of genocide and Isis would be
hard to make a game out of but again
that's just my personal opinion I
wouldn't be confident making a game out
of it finally it seems that destiny 2 is
officially in the works Muse it's
causing a lot of us to scratch our heads
since we're still waiting on the DLC
from the first game Activision
Publishing CEO Eric Hirshberg spoke
about destiny on a post-earnings
financial call saying work has also
begun on future expansion packs as well
as on our next full game release we had
previously seen contract details between
Activision and bungie which calls the
multiple sequels and we're talking about
Activision the company that publishes
call of duty so
isn't completely shocking we also
learned that 9.5 million people are
registered users in destiny and the
average user is playing the game 3 hours
a day ask me a question of the day let
me know what setting you would like to
see Call of Duty hit up next and you can
stop by my gist episode this week which
deals with just that if you're asked in
more news you can head to GameSpot's for
stories on Just Cause 3 and the leaked
halo 5 cutscene that's it for me today
thanks for joining me once again and
i'll catch you same time tomorrow